well in eight on your side catalytic  converter thefts have soared 1200  percent between 2019 and 2021 and it's  hitting drivers in the wallet mechanics  say the device is vital to drive your  cars as it helps with pollution and  while replacing it can get pricey it's  actually what's inside the converter  that makes it so expensive  you'll have probably at least a thousand  dollars worth of precious metals in a  catalytic converter  all right this year alone 36 states are  working on legislation to regulate how  they they're bought and sold but in the  meantime car experts say always be  mindful when you're parking your car to  help keep it away from thieves  well i've